brennick it's lovely to see here today a
collector mania how you've been enjoying
it so far yeah it's been great it's my
first convention like this so yes just
really great to be here now you've had a
fantastic season on Game of Thrones of
course you're not one of the book
characters but you've had quite a good
part built up by mr. Dave Hill haven't
you no I just can't believe it like I
went from my audition and I was a one
Scene part and then to suddenly be in
two series with a major storyline and
each it's it's great yeah it's the best
job I've had in ages is just incredible
how did he thank Dave when he found out
it was him who did it suggested that you
enjoyed the Nights Watch and kill
Ygritte I've not actually met Dave so
Dave if you're watching I thank you
wholeheartedly for this opportunity
but yeah yeah it's just mental it's
crazy now of course you see me this
season sword training with Jon Snow what
was that like tell me about filming that
well obviously it's every teenage boy's
dream to be having a sword fight but to
be having a sword fight with Jon Snow
you know that's just like the best thing
that could happen so when I when I read
the scripts and found out I had that I
was like yeah yeah this is gonna be good
and then I went for a day of training
with the stuntmen and his some three
guys who are the best stunt men in the
world like and it was really it was
intense but it was quite easy to pick up
like they made it simple for me to learn
and then film and it took a day and it
was it was great fun just really really
grateful what did you think when you saw
Jon Snow mercy kill mance rayder and
tell me a little bit about how they
filmed it oh well I'll tell you about
the filming first well basically you had
care and new plays mance and he was on
the he was on the pyre and he was doing
all of his acting with her just a lit
type underneath him to give the flame
effect and then they did one with a
stunt man who had a fire suit on and
they set him on fire and then afterwards
they they put him out and then just to
let it just burn they put a dummy on in
Karen's costume and they they burnt that
so it was incredible with the way that
they did it in three separate stages but
still managed to put it together in
such a fluid way yeah that's great and
Janice lint as well that beheading I was
quite happy about that as my character
because you know you got a if someone's
not taking orders you've got to show a
bit of justice but Dom the guy who plays
him is an absolutely lovely guy and we
missed him on set after that we really
did and of course we've has Ali's
reaction we've seen him react to how
John's been dealing with the Wildings of
season hasn't way and he's not a happy
chappy I mean in fact when we saw his
reaction when John came back from
hardhome whoo that was yeah it was a
very tense moment when when the eyes
caught across the courtyard it was it
was quite a weird thing to film because
obviously in the previous series we've
had this close relationship with John
and Allie and him treating him like a
younger brother and then then we have
this conflict and I don't think all he
wants the conflict all he wants to be
able to trust him but in the back of his
mind he's always got this thing of these
people killed my parents and he's not
sure he'll ever be able to get over that
do you think you mentioned there about
John treating him like a younger brother
do you think John sees kind of bran or
Rickon in him you know definitely I
think I think he sees he sees the life
he's left behind in Winterfell in in me
and so he wants to he wants to treat me
the way he thinks I'm I deserve to be
treated and do what is best for me but
also he realizes that we're going to be
adding to the army of the Dead tenfold
if we keep these people on the other
side of the wall and I think all he can
understand that but he doesn't want to
accept it and that's what's making it
hard for him to choose which side he's
going to be on of course John has seen
the White Walkers he's come back and
lived to tell the tale I mean all he has
earned he's just got to take his word
for it I mean what how do you think he'd
cope if he'd been there have he'd seen
them what do you think all he would do
if he was faced with a white Walker I
think that Olly he talked a good game
like he says in the training scene in
series 4 he says I was the best archer
in my village and stuff like that but as
you see when he's in the battlefield
before Sam speaks to him he's just
sitting in a corner rocking so in that
sense he's not really any better than
Jocelin he's like he talked a good game
but when it comes through it he's
probably a bit of a coward he was able
to take out eager it though with one
fell swoop wasn't here and that little
exchange that little smile between
between you know the little nod between
you and John snow as well and that that
nod has started a trend on the internet
I've now got a tumblr page going on
about me which is just called only nods
at things and it's basically just gifts
of me nodding from Game of Thrones so so
yeah that seems to have had more of an
impact than I thought it would but but
yeah yeah it was a it was a great scene
to film and Rose was lovely and I was
sad to see I go yeah and then of course
earlier that season you had that kind of
exchange with the sands didn't you not
very nice exchange you were on the worst
side of it obviously yeah it was um it
was a really really good scene to film
because these two massive guys Jose and
Joe and Yuri both absolutely lovely guys
but in the scene yanking me out of that
thing in holding a knife to my throat
there was just a really intense scene to
film and I loved it yeah of course how
excited are you for people to see that
season 10 episode that big finale
I can't wait it in my opinion from what
I know of it it's the best episode of
the whole series so far so yeah in terms
of what can we expect how would you say
kind of what level kind of excitement of
darkness of you know adventure action
whatever without giving anything away I
think that all all the major storylines
something happens that is worth talking
about so even if you're not interested
in the Nights Watch if you're interested
in Aria or Stannis or the Bolton's
there's something to talk about that all
that will make you quite pleased with
that episode because there's been a lot
of leaks this season have know between
the episodes and photographs on the
episodes and so on and they've been some
as well from through so 10 I mean how
how do you feel about that oh I know
that the people that like loved the show
will want to watch it at the highest
quality they can watch it and at the
time when everyone else is going to be
talking about it and I think that that
all that really matters with the people
that are the real fans of the show
watching it at the time when it's been
released by the creators so yeah it
doesn't really bother me that it's been
leaked obviously it's a shame that some
of these surprises won't have the same
wow factor that they would have had but
you know it's just people in the
internet these days you know now of
course I mean fans of Game of Thrones
you'll love to speculate but what's
gonna happen next it's so and so gonna
be in it I'll were there gonna go what's
a good subplot gonna be will they kill
this person off that person off and of
course it's been a lot of talk about
Benjen stock since we last summer a very
long time ago John John snows uncle of
course lots of series it's returning how
he might return how much would you like
to see that well I've got so many
theories going on in my head that none
of them have been confirmed there
anything and it's so frustrating because
they I've got the theory of who's going
to be on the throne or the Benjen one I
would like benjin to come back but as a
white I would love to see him come back
as a white and to see that face-off
between him and John because John in one
way is like right this guy's going to
kill me if I don't do something but then
again can either can II destroyed the
last part of his previous life at
Winterfell and it's just going to be
theirs if that happened it would it
would be very very tough to say yeah
absolutely no that's a good point I mean
you mentioned that about that I mean do
you think that John would be capable of
doing it to someone else he was close to
him so when he'd built up affection for
if he had to you know take them out I
mean freeze on for you with the one who
had to deal with Ygritte weren't you
yeah I think that even though everyone
in Game of Thrones has got a very dark
side to them even the nice people like
you've seen in sands of this series but
I think that John is one of the only
characters that when faced with the
choice of goods or bad he will always
automatically just go for the good and
he if he was told to take out someone
that he he thought a lot of I don't
think he would now of course talking
about taking people out we've seen some
gruesome some spectacular some shocking
deaths on Game of Thrones if you had to
pop your clogs how would you like to go
as Ollie oh if I had to go I'd probably
say
during battle killing lots of wildlings
I think that would be the way that he'd
want to go but who knows you can dream
is Olly Courtney who that's exactly how
I'd like to go I mean what was it like
working with of course he works a lot
with Kit Harington there's John Bradley
and you mentioned rows as well from last
season Owen Teale and Hannah Murray all
those guys it's just incredible you've
got such a wealth of acting ability in
there that I've just learnt so much from
this job just from watching other people
but I think that even though I've worked
with so many people the person I've
learned the most from is probably John
Bradley because I did the scene that was
in Episode eight with him and that took
a day to film and watching him doing his
his lines about John it was just really
eye-opening about how much you can
achieve with just a few simple lines of
course son well said to him that you
know there's difficult decisions that a
man has to make like Jon Snow Lord
Commander other people might not
understand them but you know he has to
make them what do you think Holly might
have taken on board from that I think he
might have I think all you might have
accepted the fact that okay I may not
like it but if I'm going to lead one day
as John says that he might do if I'm
going to lead obviously I'm going to be
in that position where some of the
brothers aren't gonna be happy with the
decision I make but you know I think
that still in the back of his mind he's
thinking these people killed my parents
I'm not just gonna let that slide so
yeah and of course he asked John I mean
before he had that conversation with Sam
about and whether he was just trying to
lure the wildlings into a trap didn't he
yeah because I think that he wanted to
believe that but deep down he knew that
John was too much of a good person to
play such like mind games and tricks
with someone if he was trying to save
them he would genuinely be trying to
save them and that's what's making it
hard for Olly is but is the fact that he
he hates John for the decision he's made
but you can understand it and that's the
thing that's really hard for him
now of course we always like to look
ahead with Game of Thrones as well don't
we and and wondering how likely one of
the chances are that we'll see you for a
season six and if we did what would you
like to see your character ollie get up
to I don't I don't know anything about
that
obviously I'd love to because it's just
such a fun show to film and it's the
best job I've had in my life it's opened
so many doors for me but if I came back
I think that in my eyes Ollie wouldn't
let this stand about the wildlings
living in his old village he would
probably go off by by himself
and attempt to take out a few of the
wildlings and probably die in the
process that's that's what I'd like to
see him there any way it could be really
interesting and it could be really
interesting because you've got the whole
the possibility of John going after him
and there being another wall with the
wildlings but the White Walkers coming
down as well there's so much scope for
the season six in the north and we've
not even seen anything of bran in the
whole in the whole of season five and
that's a story that I as soon as they
got to the three-eyed Raven I was like
okay do something now and then we've not
seen him but I'm really intrigued about
where that storyline could go it could
be crucial to like the whole plot of
Westeros and that whole kind of walking
as well those walking abilities of
really interesting aren't they what do
you think about that yeah I think that
it would be a really it's a really
useful tool for brand to have especially
seeming as East not that powerful in his
own body and the fact that he could warg
into
Hodor shows that you might be able to
walk into something powerful and my my
dream is that bran will one day be able
to walk into the Dragons that is that is
what I want that's one of my theories
because I've got so many mates at school
and my drama school that love the show
and they've got hundreds and hundreds of
theories about where the story could go
and that's one of the great things about
the show is that everyone's got theories
but no one really knows so you're always
left guessing now with you know the
limit of the books as well we're all
guessing but readers are not on way I
mean if you think about so we're talking
about the war game but I see some bran
that would be awesome saying and worgen
to Drago when they're I mean
but do you think it's something that
only he has or I mean do you think this
is a stark thing or what I think it
could be a stark thing and if it's a
stark thing then that means that quite
possibly John would have it if he is
stark after all and Arya would have it
so I think that that would be that would
be quite an interesting thing if it was
a stark thing then it would add a whole
other layer to the to the storyline yeah
definitely
he mentioned of course Jon Snow being
Lord Commander as the years and you're a
steward what's it been like being Jon
Snow's steward and what kind of Lord
Commander do you think he makes it's
been quite interested in being a steward
because at the beginning I was obviously
all he was thrilled to be his his mate
his mate steward at the wall but now
that there's that conflict between them
it could be quite awkward and tense and
that could lead to further conflicts but
I think that even though all the
conflict that we've had I think all he
does think that Jon is a strong
commander and a good commander is
Brannick we do voted for John as low
commander well judging by the other
options like that old Dennis malice
though I had no idea who he was or sir
Alice oh he's just a mony piece of yeah
so no I would probably have gone for
John not because he's that great leader
but because he was the best of a bad
bunch but we know you as a singer as
well from your YouTube channel don't we
I know you've writings on your own songs
at the moment as well tell us a little
bit more about that and also if you had
to make a musical episode of Game of
Thrones what kind of songs did you love
to see in that and why all that that's a
tough one there's so many possibilities
because obviously there's the whole idea
of writing new songs for it or there's
putting pop songs in it but I think that
there definitely with the Stannis
there'd be I set fire to the rain that
would that would be in there at some
point or burn baby burn
especially after episode 9 but but yeah
I think that it would be quite
interesting to have a musical episode
especially after the
the Coldplay Game of Thrones musical
recently that's been quite interesting
yeah I've been doing my own covers and
covers of other people's songs on there
for a couple of years now and it's just
it's just great fun to do and I just
started off as a bit of a laugh and then
people started watching them and now I'm
trying to write my own stuff and I'm
trying to put myself out there and get
any gigs I can so yeah it's a lots more
singing from you lots more of you on TV
as well I know you've got a Dickens show
coming up on BBC haven't you just
quickly let us know what that is it's
basically a mash-up of all of Charles
Dickens storylines so you've got like
Fagin in the same road as ebony czar
Scrooge and it's just a really fun show
and I'm about to start filming that so
yeah it should be good we look forward
to more singing and look forward to lots
more game appearances you as well it's
been lovely talking to you Brian and
thank you very much thanks for having me
you